das hier ist das perfekte Rührei so
weich dass es sich streichen lässt und
es ist wirklich unglaublich einfach
und die Zutaten sind dieselben wie bei
jedem Rührei Eier bisschen Butter und
Salz Salz zu den Eiern und verquirlen je
kleiner die Schüssel desto besser hier
ist wichtig dass wir die Eier wirklich
komplett verküren jetzt kann ich schon
mal meinen Schnittlauch schneiden gehört
einfach dazu wir haben eine beschichtete
Pfanne auf Temperatur kommen lassen und
nehmen uns jetzt einen guten Stich
Butter den wir direkt hineingeben die
muss direkt schmelzen aber nicht
verbrennen wir bleiben die gesamte Zeit
über bei der gleichen Hitze wenn die
Butter komplett geschmolzen ist geben
wir unser Ei hinzu und Fangen von Anfang
an an zu rühren das ist der Geheimtipp
es bilden sich auf dem Boden so kleine
sämige Fäden vom Ei die wir jedes Mal
wieder abziehen und in Bewegung halten
man sieht schon wie das ein bisschen
Stock und das ist auch genau der Punkt
wo wir es von der Hitze nehmen das
können wir einfach abseits der Hitze
noch ein bisschen durchführen und diese
perfekte Creme eines Rührer ist dass
sich perfekt streichen lässt